es sieht so einfach aus zwei
handbewegungen ein bisschen
konzentration und schon ist ein portal
geöffnet durch das man ohne zeitverlust
zu anderen orten reisen kann zum
beispiel in die popcorn dimension ja
okay und scheint die pop band wird ein
bisschen durch so dass ich im kopf klar
genau das können wir gerade wieder auf
der leinwand sehen doctor strange ist
quasi der profi unter dem portal öffnen
von marvel aber das ist ja alles nur
fiktion oder kreative ideen von
hollywood drehbuchautoren ok aber was
ist dann mit diesem paper hier von
niemand geringerem als albert einstein
und wie war das noch mal mit der
krümmung von raum zeit könnte das portal
vielleicht doch in der realität geben
genau darum geht es heute bei doctor
strange
dr
also zunächst einmal will macht es sich
ganz schön einfach denn doctor strange
öffnet seine portale einfach durch magie
das ist natürlich praktisch denn da muss
man nicht so viel erklären alles was ist
range für seine reisen tun muss ist sich
seinen zielort mit voller konzentration
vorzustellen dann noch ein paar gesten
mit so einem ding an der hand und schutz
das funken portal ist offen das klappt
in der realen welt so natürlich nicht
wir menschen haben es nicht so mit magie
und mit unserer technik sind wir bisher
gerade mal 20 milliarden kilometer weit
gekommen nämlich mit der sonde voyager
aber das sind nur achtung
0,000 000 000 05 prozent des
beobachtbaren universums von den weiten
die sich vielleicht noch hinter unserem
beobachtungs horizont erstrecken ganz zu
schweigen und selbst wenn wir mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit reisen könnten
während wir bis zu unserem nachbar stern
proxima centauri gute vier jahre
unterwegs nicht sogar vier sekunden wie
doctor strange wir brauchen also
effektivere wege um einmal quer wird
unser universum zu reisen okay wie wär's
denn mit wohnen löchern ein wurmloch ist
eine so starke veränderung des traums
dass zwei pferde punkte durch diese
verformung plötzlich sehr nah
beieinander liegen so nahe dass man
durch diesen tunnel das wurmloch sehr
schnell von einem punkt zum anderen
kommt eine galaktische abkürzung quasi
so eine abkürzung in andere galaxien
kann ganz schön hilfreich sein ich meine
wer kennt es nicht nach einem
anstrengenden tag als fleißiger
asteroiden pharma möchte man sich abends
ganz entspannt die intergalaktische
formel 1 ansehen und merkt dass portman
ist jetzt echt nur noch in messi 63
verfügbar
hätte man jetzt ein wurmloch zur
verfügung oder den sponsor des heutigen
videos denn jpn ist quasi das ultimative
digitale wohnung noch mit dem kannst du
nicht nur in zwei sondern bis zu 60
ländern sein damit hast du zugriff auf
das streaming angebot aus all diesen
ländern und musste ich nicht mit
nervigen geo blocking rumschlagen über
österreichs ist servus tv kannst du dir
so zum beispiel die aktuelle formel 1
kostenlos auch hier in deutschland
ansehen dazu bietet jpn jetzt auch einen
bedrohungs schutz an den du einfach
aktivieren kannst der schütze deinen pc
oder laptop vor schädlichen websites und
dateien aus dem internet unabhängig
davon ob gerade eine verbindung zu einem
vpn server besteht außerdem blockiert er
nervige pop up werbung und auch das
tracking deiner daten nur wie pm selbst
speichert nachgewiesenermaßen keine
daten über das surfverhalten ist
superschnell auf tablet laptop oder
computer installiert und in den ersten
30 tagen auch genauso schnell und
kostenfrei wieder weg falls du es dir
anders überlegen sollte ist und wenn wir
unsere code doktor watson oder den link
nord wie pr.com / doktor watson nutzt
bekommst du bei einem zwei jahres paket
sogar einen monat gratis dazu und
unterstützt damit auch noch uns und
unsere videos und damit nehmen wir
direkt wieder das nächste wurmloch
zurück zum thema also auf geht's oder
auch nicht denn bohrlöcher sind noch
unzuverlässiger als die deutsche bahn
außerhalb von marvel universum gibt es
an allen ecken und enden probleme
problem nummer eins keiner kann
vorhersagen wann und wo ein wurmloch
entstehen wird der theoretische rock
around aus der physik kommt hier unter
anderem vom nobelpreisträger kipp von
der auch wissenschaftlicher berater für
den film interstellar war und dieser
workaround heißt exotische materie das
ist ein hypothetisches material mit
negativer masse und anderen negativen
energiedichte dann sollte das material
hätte durch seine negative masse anti
gravitative eigenschaften das heißt
würde normale masse abstoßen wenn man es
dann in der mitte eines wurmloch
platziert dann würde es in der theorie
ein wurmloch offen halten das problem
ist nur nach den prinzipien der
klassischen physik kann es keine materie
geben sie eine anti gravitative wirkung
entfaltet auch die negative energie
dichte galt lange als phänomen das man
nicht nachweisen kann doch stephen
hawkings erkennen dass sie zur physik
der schwarzen löcher und zur sogenannten
hawking strahlung könnten eine lösung
parat haben aus ihnen lässt sich
ableiten dass das scheinbar leere vakuum
des raumes voller paare von teilchen und
antiteilchen ist die ständig entstehen
und wieder verschwinden diese sogenannte
quantenfluktuationen bedeutet dass
dieses vakuum gar nicht so leer ist
sondern ein energieniveau bis ist würde
man jetzt zwei parallele metallplatten
ganz eng nebeneinander in diesen leeren
raum stellen dann hätte die
quantenfluktuationen dazwischen weniger
fläche zur verfügung
es würde also weniger fluktuation
stattfinden dadurch hat der raum
zwischen den platten eine geringere
energie als außerhalb und die folge wäre
die raumzeit wäre negativ gekrümmt einen
beweis dass dieser sogenannte kasimir
effekt funktionieren könnte gibt es aber
noch nicht und das weiß auch noch
niemand wie man diese negative energie
dazu bewegen kann ein wurmloch zu formen
aber wenn das klappen würde dann hätten
wir vielleicht eine möglichkeit
eventuell diese exotische materie zu
erzeugen ganz vielleicht zu exotischen
materie werden auch regelmäßig paper
veröffentlicht und auf verschiedene
hypothetische wurmloch szenarien
angewandt das alles bleibt aber im
bereich der theoretischen physik in der
realität ist uns zumindest noch nichts
derartiges bekannt deshalb ist auch
unklar wie exotisch materie am ende mit
uns menschen wechselwirken wurde
schließlich müssen wir irgendwie an ihr
vorbei um durch das wurmloch zu reisen
aber das war noch lange nicht alles
kommen wir mal zu problemen nummer zwei
geringe überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit
nehmen wir an wir bekommen ein stabiles
verlässliches schönes wurmloch im
inneren eines schwarzen lochs aufgebaut
toll bloß und da jetzt durch zu kommen
müssen wir erstmal durch das schwarze
loch durch und das endet allen
hochrechnungen zufolge für menschen er
tödlich mittlerweile vermutet die
forschung das zumindest unsere
informationen wieder herauskommen
könnten mehr dazu haben übrigens in
diesem video erklärt dabei alles andere
spucken schwarze löcher hat zumindest
nicht so wieder aus dass man zeitnah da
wird irgendetwas anfangen könnte es sei
denn es gibt die hier
weiße löcher sind wie schwarze löcher
nur eben rückwärts anstatt alles in sich
hinein gezogen wird wie das bei
schwarzen löchern der fall ist stoßen
weicher materie und strahlung aus der
österreichische physiker ludwig flammen
hatte sie erstmals vor 100 jahren auf
der grundlage von einsteins gleichungen
beschrieben
1935 legte dann ein stein persönlich
nach als er entdeckte dass bei manchen
mathematischen theorie singularitäten
herauskamen versuchte er direkt sie
quasi deck zu rechnen hierfür
entwickelte er gemeinsam mit jay rosen
eine theorie bei der ein teilchen es
vermeiden kann für immer von einem
schwarzen loch verschluckt zu werden
statt dessen kann es über eine
verbindung zwischen zwei solchen löchern
entkommen mathematisch gesprochen
vorausgesetzt es ist schneller als licht
was gewöhnliche teilchen nicht sind über
diese sogenannte einstein rosen brücke
könnte das überlichtschnelle teilchen
also in ein schwarzes loch gefallen und
aus einem anderen wieder raus kommen und
dieses andere das wäre dann ein weißes
loch 1957 kaufte der physiker archibald
wheeler diese einstein rosen brücken wo
in löcher und damit waren sie aus der
science fiction welt quasi nicht mehr
wegzudenken aber nur weil ein stein
seine hände im spiel hatte heißt das ja
noch lange nicht dass es weiße löcher
auch unbedingt geben muss laut dem
berühmten physiker roger penrose sind
sie zum beispiel nicht möglich und auch
dem zweiten hauptsatz der thermodynamik
widersprechen sie die
relativitätstheorie kümmert sich aber
generell nur bedingt um die gesetze der
thermodynamik nach ihr könnt es solche
gebilde auf jeden fall geben wurmlöcher
und weiße löcher existieren tatsächlich
als exakte lösungen der relativität
gleichungen einsteins sind also
zumindest mathematisch korrekt aber
selbst wenn wir am anderen ende durch
ein weißes loch unbeschadet aus der
ganzen geschichte wieder herauskommen
löst das nicht problem nummer drei
dadurch stellt das mal ganz gerührt er
weg
ok problem nummer drei und das ist
ziemlich lustig man weiß nämlich nie wo
man herauskommt doctor strange muss sich
einfach nur den ort stark genug
vorstellen aber im realen leben hätten
wir keine ahnung wohin uns das wurmloch
portal führt es sei denn wir könnten
unsere eigenen löcher aufbauen das würde
uns dann auch mit problemen mafia helfen
nämlich schwarze löcher sind nicht
gerade um die ecke selbst wenn unser
nachbar loch im zentrum der milchstraße
ein wurmloch für uns erzeugen würde dann
müssten wir daher erstmal hinkommen und
mit knapp 26 tausend lichtjahren ist es
so weit weg dafür bräuchte man
eigentlich schon wieder ein wurmloch um
da überhaupt erst hinzu kommen am besten
hier in der nähe der erde aber so ein
wurmloch habe ich mal gehört braucht ein
schwarzes loch und davon würde ich eher
abraten außerdem wäre der energiebedarf
enorm hierzu gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche hochrechnungen die bbc
schreibt zb das für ein wo noch von der
größe einer grapefruit die energie
unserer sonne aus 100 millionen jahre
nötig wäre müssen also noch ein bisschen
daran arbeiten an unserer energiewende
aber das kann doch alles ganz anders
sein verlassen wir mal die welt der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie und der
klassischen physik vielleicht
funktionieren wurmlöcher ja mittels
quanten ein kandidat ist die
quantenverschränkung ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht dass es dieses etwas
gruselige konzept bei der zwei quanten
sozusagen telepathisch miteinander
verbunden sind verändert sich das eine
verändert sich auch sein zwilling auch
wenn der am anderen ende des universums
ist da diese veränderung zeitgleich
stattfindet müssen die beiden teilchen
schneller als licht miteinander
kommunizieren quantenverschränkung jetzt
zwei schwarze löcher miteinander könnte
sich daraus ein wurmloch formen
diese theorie ist als apple ceo bekannt
und man könnte mathematisch gesprochen
sogar hindurch reisen astronauten die an
beiden enden dieses bohrlochs
gleichzeitig hinein fliegen könnten sich
beispielsweise in der mitte treffen und
sich helfen und ihr treffen wäre sogar
von den eingängen aus sichtbar sagen
einige forschende mega cool aber leider
auch mega langsam denn die
physikalischen gesetze erfordern dass
alles was durch so ein wurmloch
hindurchgeht eine art zeitlichen
verzögerung unterliegt der weg durch das
wurmloch darf nicht kürzer dauern als
der weg durch die normale raumzeit wir
können uns also teleportieren ja aber
während keine sekunde schneller als wenn
wir einfach normal geflogen wären nur
zum spritsparen ist es super das alles
heißt einfach mal so ein portal öffnen
wie doctor strange können wir nicht
mathematisch denkbar sind solche portale
durch den raum aber schon die
wissenschaft untersucht aktuell ob man
mittels anderer gravitationstheorie
negativer energiedichten erzeugen könnte
sodass wurmlöcher auch ohne exotische
materie funktionieren nur ob wir die
reise hin durch überleben es bleibt
fraglich
total check check bist du das
patrick ich habe ich endlich gefunden
ein glück heil war das so schwierig ein
mega schwierig ich hab's dutzend mal
probiert bin immer irgendwo anders raus
gekommen ich hab so viele varianten von
doktor watson gesehen eine mit tentakeln
das klingt ganz komisch sind das andere
version von mir in anderen universen
häufig funktioniert das ganz genau ganz
genau und mit diesem multiversum haben
wir uns in unserer folge beschäftigt
denn wir haben geguckt wie das in echt
aussehen könnte in der wissenschaft gibt
es dann nämlich einige theorien dazu und
die drei populärsten die haben wir uns
angeschaut und klären dabei unter
anderem auf ein universum komplett aus
käse bestehen könnte warum doctor
strange höllisch aufpassen muss nicht
das falsche universum zu erwischen und
in wie vielen metern entfernung eine
exakte kopie von dir existiert das
klingt mega spannend ich gucke mir
sofort euer video an bis dann wir sehen
uns
also genauso wie ich könnte jetzt auch
das video von jack gucken klickt einfach
hier genau da wo seine partei gerade war
und ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick